I love practical jokes this is my best
one ever
my buddy asked me to throw him a
bachelor party and I was like man you
want me to do that I said I'm a comedian
I always go for the laughs then I hope
we can shake hands and be friends later
but I'm gonna [ __ ] up your day and he
was like I don't think you'll do that I
said I don't think you're listening I'm
already trying to decide how to [ __ ]
with you so can we just like not have me
do it and he was like buddy you've been
to Vegas more than any of us you planned
the party you get the girl now look I
got him a girl for the end of his party
that's what he wanted a stripper I'm not
a stripper guy I never have been a
stripper guy I don't really care but he
wanted a stripper at the end of his
party that's cool I wanted the beginning
of the party to be for me and what did I
want to watch what do I like way more
than strippers I like weird [ __ ] guys if
you're like a man this is about to be
some weird [ __ ] happen in alley I'm like
I'm a [ __ ] watch that
100% I love it how weird I wanted people
walking out of his party like this what
the [ __ ] just happened in there
like with some guy walking out with a
limp like why are my hands dirty like
weird [ __ ] right where did I think I
could find that I went on Craigslist in
Vegas well guys I have never felt so
horny and sad at the same time in my
entire life
scrolling through scroll through it's
all sex stuff I don't want that one
weird and then we are jumped out the
screen of me
this woman's advertisement was three
words that's it and those three words
were I'll wrestle yeah and I was like
[ __ ] yeah you will that at least
deserves a phone call I think right I
call her on the phone she is 6 foot 2 50
and her special skill is that she'll
come over to your house she'll get naked
and she'll toss you around for a little
while
[Laughter]
I was like well what time can you get
here so she shows up and I open the door
and she's legitimate six foot two fifty
right and she's holding a footlong sub
in twenty four buffalo wings
not kidding and she waves him in my face
and she goes you got a room where I
could go fuel up before the match and I
was like first of all [ __ ] yes I do
right in there and I said second of all
you should know that the person you're
wrestling today doesn't know there's
going to be a match
you know I don't know if that changes
your professional approach at all so she
goes off into her room my buddy comes
over and we've got him stool just like
this one and my other friends are
standing behind him when we get him
blindfolded and he's well I don't want
to ruin the surprise you know and he's
like no this chair is one Ralphie may
away from an accident I'll tell ya oh
you don't think he knows he's 900 pounds
he [ __ ] knows so um
he's sitting there and he's like I'm so
excited
me too and he says I'm ready and I said
okay and I call her out now none of my
other friends knew what I had planned so
when she walked out of that room naked
collectively they were like
[Music]
and as she got closer I said she still
had buffalo wing sauce around I was
gonna get her napkin but I was like I'm
sorry that [ __ ] is too funny on your
face I am so sorry so she stands in
front of him six for 250 well I forgot
to tell you the best part my buddy five
eight and one forty and like oh like a
like a like a soft one forty right so
the size difference alone like I don't
know what's gonna happen but I'm pretty
sure I'm gonna [ __ ] like it
[Music]
and he says I'm ready and I said okay
and I take off his blindfold and the
only word he could get out of his mouth
before she ripped him out of his chair
[Music]
was why
[Laughter]
and she lifted him up like this his
little feet were dangling in the air
she's gonna toss him around the room
like a rag doll
we were rolling guys she would jump on
top of him and he had to push her found
out of his face to talk to us
you'd be like Kelly stop
I want you gonna be here I can't breathe
what does she smell like buffalo wings
[Music]
there's one time was she was straddling
him like this beating him in the face
with her titties just I don't think
you're getting the right visual okay
guys this isn't 5 foot 2 110 pound
titties this is 6 foot 250 just titties
that's how bigger titties were they made
that noise through the air it was like
being hit with a tin missile just do
that a swollen eye from titty punches
you've never seen that in the history of
[ __ ] never ever I'll tell you that
right now so she thinks her job is done
right she walks over here to this side
of the room my buddy gets up man you
know what you can tell someone is mad
where they never take their eyes off of
that thing they're mad at so he gets up
and he walks away from her like this
[Music]
and then some minam just snapped and he
just looks at her knee goes I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up and like a wave of calm
crashed over her like serious like Bruce
Lee Enter the Dragon calm she was just
like and they ran at each other guys you
understand what's happening they're
[ __ ] fighting for real now
it's the best gift I've ever given to
myself ever are you kidding me they're
running at each other I gotta meet me
know how this is gonna end they're
running at each other and my buddy was
mad and he screamed no I'll take you
down running at each other full speed
and he ran into her I'm gonna tell you
something he really didn't try to take
her down I'll tell you what he did not
all I can tell you is that when his
little body hit hers
she kind of absorbed him for a second
and he disappeared I was like where the
[ __ ] did he go and then she just shot
him out across the room boom and he slid
on the floor and one of my friends ran
up to a woman that just bucket Happiny
out
[Music]
and she was mad that he Challenger and
something so she goes suss you want to
see my finishing move me to finish up
and I grew up with Hulk Hogan and Randy
the Macho Man Savage I was like
I didn't know she was coming off the top
rope or dropping a leg or whatever I
wanted to see that [ __ ] right so she
says to run to him and she was like
finish em and we go yeah she was
finishing moving we go yeah and she goes
you want to see the finishing move and
we go yeah and then she sat on his hand
away when not that finishing move [ __ ]
guys his little head disappeared all you
can see were his tiny arms slapping her
back like
oh it was a fight for life I'm telling
you that right now
it was the weirdest [ __ ] I've ever seen
it was like you reversed birth it was
[ __ ] up
and here's how you know you pulled a
good practical joke but good brothel
joke is a joke that continues to pay
dividends long after the joke is over so
like a month and a half after a wedding
after the party two weeks before the
wedding I ran into his dad and his dad
goes uh hey you're not coming to the
wedding
I was uninvited to the wedding that was
totally worth it totally worth it you
guys want to see how he uninvited me
so here's how his dad goes you're
knocked over the wedding I go now and he
goes why not and I said oh Tim didn't
tell you and he said no what do you got
a couple minutes sit down and then his
dad used that story as his best man
speech at the wedding
[ __ ] winner winner
[Music]
you